I remember once working with a woman who
found it really frustrating that someone
in her office loudly ate rice around
lunchtime every day and her metal
thought would constantly be hitting
against the bowl and she was so annoyed
by it that she was actually going to go
out and buy a wooden fort for this
person when you think we spend half our
waking life away if there's someone who
really gets under your skin it's crucial
to cross that divide that takes an
enormous amount of energy and it makes
little or no difference to them they've
really done something totally illegal or
horrendous
there's probably much better remedies
for it most of the time we find that
people want to avoid having a
conversation with the other person
because they dislike them but if you
don't talk about it it won't get better
by itself so some people try to put it
off and develop coping mechanisms but it
rarely makes the situation much better
and soon it's years down the line and
you're still in the same boat hating
this person it doesn't have to be like
this a bit of short-term pain ie
difficult but open and honest
conversation with the person you dislike
can bring a long-term game
we get people telling us we're
intimidating when we think we're really
cuddly or telling us that we're shy when
we consider ourselves thoughtful and
serious so think about what you give off
to other people here's Ali he's very
bright he's quite young he's very highly
educated he's just got a great job so
he's sent to a conference and because as
well as being bright he's rather modest
he decides that he'll keep quiet
pretty much and he'll just observe
what's going on and listen to people who
are more experienced the people around
him who've heard how bright he is and
how well educated see him being a bit
restrained and a bit withheld and start
to think he's a bit aloof he doesn't
rate us he thinks he's too good for us
and so they start to freeze him out we
end up with a situation where
everybody's misunderstanding each other
and nobody is getting the benefit of
their different abilities and
experiences questions and seek to
understand the other person's viewpoint
then show them you've understood their
viewpoint by summarizing back to them
what they've said an incredibly powerful
little tool for building rapport - often
people just try to persuade others of
their case but if you show that you're
open to listening to the other person
and genuinely want to understand where
they're coming from you'll have a much
more constructive conversation I
remember once in a mediation where one
person shouted at the other you're a
pathological liar now I don't have a
problem with someone saying that if
that's how they feel but I do actually
with how its worded if you tell someone
they're a liar they'll automatically
disagree we all would but if you calmly
point out that on this occasion on this
occasion they've lied to you you can
have a conversation about it without
them getting as defensive
it's probably not personal remember that
you don't have to learn to like the
person they don't conflict with you just
have to work with him you will need to
challenge your assumptions and then
learn from that welcomed other's ideas
and approaches be yourself be open be
honest about your own strengths and
contributions the really great thing is
if you're doing those things not only
does it diminish that feeling of dislike
and make you better at working with
people but you might actually get to
enjoy working with them if you like that
subscribe to the BBC ideas YouTube
channel
lots more top tips on how to be
successful at work